بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم
وبارك على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
يقول الله تعالى
وان طائفتان من المؤمنين اقتتلوا فاصلحوا
بينهما
فان بغت احداهما على الاخرى فقاتل التي
تبغي حتى تفيء الى امر الله
وان طائفتان اي وان جهتان
والطائفه
تصدق على الفرد فما فوقه فما اكثر هذه
طائفه في لغه العرب
يقولوا وان طائفتان من المؤمنين اقتتلوا
اختلفوا
فاصلحوا بينهما
فان بغت احداهما على الاخرى اي فان اعتدت
احداهما على الاخرى
او امتنعت احداهما
عن التنازل على او التنزل على حكم الله
او ما شابه ذلك
فقاتلوا التي تبغي التي تعتدي حتى تفيء
حتى ترجع وتعود الى امر الله
فان فاءت فان رجعت وعادت واقرت
فاصلحوا بينهما اي بين الجماعتين بالعدل
واقسطوا بالعدل بالحق بحكم الله
واقسطوا اي اعطوا كل ذي حق حقه
والقسط
هو
اعطاء الحق
اعطاء قسط المحق
والاقساط
والقاسط على وزن فاعل هو اخذ قسط الغير
الذي ليس له
فالمقسط هو الذي يعطي حق غيره
ويؤدي حق الغير
والقاصق هو الذي ياخذ حق الغير
هنا يقول واقسطوا
يعني وادوا كل ذي حق حقه بين الجماعتين ان
الله يحب المقسطين العادلين
انما المؤمنون اخوه اي ليسوا اقل من ذلك
مهما كانت
منازلهم الاجتماعيه
ان اختلف
اصحاب الاموال واصحاب
المقامات العليا في المجتمع مع
الشباب اللي
بيصلحوا الشوارع
هما اخوه اخوه زي في الحج زي في الصلاه
كلنا بنسجد كلنا بركع هذا هو
اخوه الاسلام ولا يجوز الاخلال بذلك
ولا يجوز ان نحابي طائفه دون اخرى
ولا ان نحابي جماعه دون اخرى
فواجب على
المسلمين ان يقسطوا وان يعدلوا ولو كانوا
اولي قربه
لو كان
المحق بعيد
مدفوع بين الابواب
والظالم قريب
مرفوع
في
المقامات العليا في المجتمع
فانه لا يجوز
لاحد ان يعتدي على احد ولا يجوز
للقاضي بين المؤمنين ان يحابي
احدى الطائفتين دون الاخرى قال انما
المؤمنون اخوه فاصلحوا بين اخويكم
فلا يكفي مجرد منع الظالم لا يكفي مجرد
قول الحق لا يكفي مجرد
اعطاء
اصحاب الحقوق حقوقهم
لابد من الاصلاح لابد من الاصلاح بين
الاخوه وبين الاخوه الاسلاميه لابد وهذا
امر في السعي في
تحبيب الناس وتحبيب المسلمين من بعض هذا
امر بان يسعى
كل مسلم ان
ينم الخير بين المسلمين وان يجمع بين
قلوبهم ما استطاع الى ذلك
والله عز وجل يقول فاصلحوا بين
اخويكم وفي قراءه بعض الصحابه اخوتكم
وفي قراءه اخرى اخوانكم كلها مكتوبه بنفس
الطريقه بنفس الخط
يقول
فاصلحوا بين اخويكم
فاتقوا الله
هذا يشعر هذا الاسلوب
في الكلام يشعر بانه من لم يفعل ما تقدم
من السعي في الاصلاح
والقسط والعدل
ومقاتله في الباغيه الى غير ذلك فانه لم
يتق الله
فانما سبق من تقوى الله ومن تمام تقوى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
فان الذي يمتنع عن شيء من ذلك امتنع عن
شيء من التقوى بحسب
بحسب ما امتنع زاد ما زاد
يقول
واتقوا الله لعلكم ترحمون
فهذه اوامر قويه
يامر الله بها يقول الله سبحانه وتعالى
واصلحوا ذات بينكم
ايش يعني ذات بينكم لماذا لم يقل واصلحوا
بينكم صحيح الجمله واصلحوا بينكم
بل قال واصلحوا ذات بينكم يعني
لتبحثوا عن اصول
حقيقه الخلاف بينكم وتنتهكوها
استاصلوها هذه الاصول تستاصلها من بينكم
فان الاختلاف بين المؤمنين يؤدي الى
الاختلاف في الدين
اختلاف في الابدان الاختلاف في الحقوق
الاختلاف في المنازل الاختلاف يؤدي الى
الخلل في الدين في عباده الله
وان المؤمن يحتاج الى اخيه
حتى لو كان غنيا قويا
فانه لا بد لكل واحد منا مهما بلغ من
الغنى فلا بد ان يكون فقيرا في اكثر
احواله منه
غنيا
لان الانسان خلق اصلا فقيرا
خلق اصلا فقيرا
فقد يستغني الانسان في بعض احواله لكن
الغالب عليه الفقر
فالمؤمن يستعين باخيه المؤمن للمؤمن
كالبنيان يشد بعضه بعضه الله عز وجل ارسل
موسى عليه السلام
ارسله واتاه من الايات ما اتاه واصلح له
ما وجد في وحل له عقده من لسانه وايده
بنور
واشياء عظيمه
فلم يكتفي بذلك موسى عليه السلام طلب ان
يرسل الى اخيه هارون وان يرسله معه نبيه
وان يعضده به
فالانسان لا يستغني عن اخيه ابدا
وكل ما كان الانسان
اتقى لله كل ما كان اهم
كل ما كان اهم في المجتمع المسلم
ليس المقصود غنى المال ولا غنى النفس
وتقوى الله والعلم الشرعي هذا الذي ينجي
المؤمنين في الدنيا والاخره
فبحسب ما قام
بالقلب من الايمان
تكون الاخوه اشد واشد فقال الله تعالى
انما المؤمنون اخوه
انما
لاحظوا اللفظ هنا انما المؤمنون اخوه يعني
اقل احوال المؤمنين انهم اخوه
هذه اقل احوال النسب بين المؤمنين
فاصلحوا بين اخويكم فاتقوا الله لعلكم
ترحمون فجعل ما سبق من الاوامر
شريطه
وشرطا في رحمه الله ونيل تقوى الله سبحانه
وتعالى وهذه عظيمه
والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
وصف الاختلاف بين المؤمنين بالحالقه
بالحالقه التي تحلق
قال فانها لا تحلق الراس ولكن تحلق تحلق
الدين
انتهك الدين
كالحالقه
والذي يستخف بالاخوه الاسلاميه
الاخوه الشرعيه هو المنافق
المنافقون هم الذين
يستخفون بالاخوه الشرعيه
انظر الى صفه المنافقين في القران
يشيعون الاشاعات يقولون الاقوال يتتبعون
الاخطاء يتتبعون يعظمون
يعظمون اخطاء المؤمنين البراء
ويحقرون احوالهم الطيه هذه صفات المنافقين
الذين يحقرون
المسلمين
والاخوه الاسلاميه
وهذا في الغالب الاخوه الاسلاميه الخوه
الشرعيه
تجد انه لا يسعى فيها الا المؤمن الصادق
ولا يستحقرها
ويسعى في افسادها الا المنافق
المنافقون يسعون
بالفساد بين المؤمنين الله عز وجل يقول في
المنافقين ولا اوضعوا خلالكم
يبغونكم الفتنه
هكذا وصفهم
اخوه الشرعيه
يبغضها
من اراد ان يتسلط على الناس
الذي يريد ان يتسلط على الناس
يبغض
الاخوه الشرعيه انظر الى هذه الحكومات
الظالمه الغاشمه
فانهم يبغضون
الاخوه الاسلاميه
ولا يعبئون
بمن اراد ان يصلحها وسعى في اصلاحها ولا
ياخذون على يد من اراد ان
يكثر الخلافات بين المسلمين بل ان
الحكومات كثيره ما تجد ان الناس مجتمعين
يجدون ان الناس مثلا مجتمعون على عالم او
مجتمعون على دعوه فياتون ويفسدون بينهم
ويفسدون سمعه هذا العالم ويفسدونه سمع
ويراقبونه ويفعلون ويفعلون لماذا
لان الاخوه الشرعيه
بتخوفهم
ونفس الشيء مع اذا نظرت مثلا الى فرعون في
القران نفس القصه
واذا نظرت الى المسلمين
فانك تجد فيما بينهم
المنافقون المدسوسون بينهم وهم يتكلمون
بلسانهم
هم من بني جلدتهم
ويتكلمون بنفس نبره المؤمنين
هؤلاء المنافقون وقد يظنون انفسهم من خيره
الناس وهم المؤمنون حقا هكذا يرون انفسهم
تجدهم يستحقرون المسلمين المتحابين
فاذا كان الله سبحانه وتعالى امر بالاخوه
هكذا امر بهذه الاخوه وامر بهذا السعي من
رؤساء الناس
يعني هذه الاوامر الى كل المسلمين وجماعه
المسلمين
وحكومه المسلمين
اذا رايتم كذا وكذا فلا بد من السعي في
الاصلاح توقف جميع الامور تحط كل المشاغل
على جنب وتسعى في الاصلاح بين المسلمين
اذا كانت المساله هكذا
فما بالك بالذي يسعى
في الافساد بين المسلمين
يعني ليس
اذا كان الذي يمتنع
عن
الاصلاح بين المفسدين بين المسلمين فانه
لم يتقي الله فكيف بمن فعل ضد ذلك
وسعى في الافساد بين المسلمين
هذا
يا ويله اعوذ بالله سبحانه وتعالى من ذلك
يقول يا ايها الذين امنوا
لا يسخر قوم من قوم عسى يكون خيرا منهم
يا ايها الذين امنوا لا يسخر
السخريه
الازدراء والتحقير
وهو القول المشعر بالازدراء والتحقير هذا
يسمى
سخريه
ويقول يا ايها الذين امنوا لا يسخر اي لا
يستحقر ولا
يستقل
قوم من قوم عسى ان يكونوا خيرا منهم
وهذا هو الغالب ان المسخور منه في الغالب
خير من الساخر
ولا نساء من نساء عسى ان يكون خيرا منهن
وهذه الايه
ترجح ان لفظ القوم للرجال
يعني اذا قال الله سبحانه وتعالى كلمه قوم
فان المقصود به ايش الرجال
دون النساء لكن قد تدخل للنساء تبعا او
تدخل من باب
العموم الذي يريد به الخصوص واحوال لكن في
اصل لغه العرب كلمه قوم يعني الرجال جماعه
من الرجال
فالله عز وجل يقول يا ايها الذين امنوا لا
يسخر قوم من قوم يعني رجال من رجال عسى ان
يكونوا خيرا منهم ولا نساء من نساء عسى ان
يكن خيرا منهن
ولا تلمزوا انفسكم اللمس
هو التحقيق
بالكلام
يعني السب
السب النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول
سباب المسلم فسوق ايش هو السباب
سب هو التحقير الكلام الذي
يقصد به اهانه
الغير او تحقير الغير
الله عز وجل يقول
يا ايها الذين
ولا تسبوا الذين يدعون من دون الله
فيسب الله عدوا بغير علم ولا تسب الذين
يدعون لماذا نهاهم الله سبحانه وتعالى عن
ذلك
بسبب رده الفعل رده الفعل
تجعلهم يسبون الله عدوا بغير علم لكن اذا
ائتمن هذا فانه الى اصل الاباحه
ايش المقصود ولا تسبوا الذين يدعون من دون
الله يعني لا
تستحقرونهم وتهينونهم في الكلام اي كلمه
يقصد بها
اهانه الغير فهذه تسمى سبا في لغه العرب
كما عرفها شيخ الاسلام رحمه الله في
الصارم المسلول
فكل كلمه يريد الانسان
ان يستحقر الخير او ان ياخذ او ان يغض من
الغير فهذه تسمى سبا وثم فرق بين السب
والكلام
الكلام
التافه او الكلام
البذيء الكلام البذيء هذا يختلف بعض الناس
يظن ان السب لا يتم حتى يكون في كلام بذيء
وهذا غلط
شيخ الاسلام رحمه الله عرف السب في الصارم
المسلول عرف السب بانه اي كلمه
قصد المتكلم بها ان
يستحقر الغير او ان يهين الغير وذكر حتى
كلمات مثل انه سيء الخلق او انه قليل
السياسه
ايش يعني قليل السياسه
يعني زلمه طيب بس بعرفش يتعامل مع الناس
هذه
تعتبر من السب
وفي فرق بين النصيحه او السب النصيحه
بتكون بضوابطها في احوالها ولا يقصد
الناصح ان ياخذ من
من يتكلم معه
لكن
الساب
يقول هذه الكلمات ويريد ان
يغضب او ان يجرح هذا الذي يتكلم فيه هذا
هو السب
وهذا السب فسوق في شريعه الاسلام اذا كان
تجاه مسلم
سباب المسلم فسوق هكذا يقول النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم
فاللمس ما هو اللمس هو السب هو الذي يكون
بالكلام
عندك اللمس وعندك الهمس
الهمس بالاشاره
واللمس بالكلام ويل لكل
همزه لمزه يعني كثير
الاهانه وسب الناس بالاشاره وبالكلام هذا
هو الهمزه الهمزه
واطلق عليه بالتانيث للمبالغه
فمعنى الكلام ويل لكل
هامز
لامز
او هماز لماس
لكن قال همزه لمزه
للمبالغه لان العرب يطلقون المؤنث على
المذكر والمذكر على المؤنث اذا ارادوا
المبالغه لا يقولون علام يقولون علامه ولا
يقولون امراه حامله يقولون امراه حامل
للمبالغه
فهنا يقول ولا تلمس انفسكم
يعني لا يجوز لاحد ان يطلق لفظه
يقصد بها اهانه اخيه المسلم مهما كانت
مهما كانت
ولو كانت محلاه
ومغموسه بالعسل
بعض الناس وبعض من يخاف الله سبحانه
وتعالى ولكن نفسه تسول له
ذكر هذا
النووي رحمه الله في كتاب
الاذكار يذكر غيبه الصالحين
يذكر سب الصالحين
ايش يعني الصالحين يعني اصحاب العلم اصحاب
التقوى
يغتابون لكن يغتابون بطريقه تختلف عن
طريقه
بقيه الناس
فمثل
فقال مثلا
يقولون الفاظا يفهم منها
يفهم منها الغيبه وهي شرعا غيبه فمثلا
يذكر فلان ويقول ويقول
حدانا الله واياه
مثلا
ايش هذا يعني هدانا الله واياه ايش يفهم
ايش يفهم المستمع من هذه اللفظه يعني
هذا التقوى وماكلت هذا
زلمه خايف على اخوه هدانا الله واياه ولا
مثلا يذكر فلان ويقول
نسال الله الثبات
ايش يعني نسال الله الثبات يعني بده
المستمع يفهم انه هذا غير ثابت على الدين
وهذا غير مهدي
وهذا قد يكون اسوا من ذكر الغيبه نفسها
الصراحه لماذا
لانها عامه مطلقه
قد يتبادر الى ذهن المستمع اشياء هو بريء
منها يعني لو خصص كان اهون
هو يقول هدانا الله واياه يعني في ذهنه
انه كثير النوم وذهب
ذهب
خاطر المستمع الى انه الرجل يفعل اشياء
تخيل بالمروء
وبعض الناس يقول
وعاده اللي بده يغتاب بده يسب عاده
ياتي بمقدمه اذا عارف انه بين جماعه
بينكروا عليه ياتي بمقدمه
حتى يمهد لشيطنته
فيقول مثلا
صراحه يعني انا بديش اغتاب استغفر الله
العظيم لكن
وبعدين بختاب
شو
هالتقوى
الرقيقه هذه الديانه الرقيقه هذه
تلاعب هذا يعني ولا يغتب بعضكم بعضا يعني
اسكت ما تحكيش ولا كلمه ولا اشاره ولا شيء
عن اخوك اشتغل بشيء اخر هذا معنى الامر بس
هذا معنى الامر
يعني ما اغتابش لا ما تغتابش ولا واحد
تحكيش شر ولا عن انسان
ولا ولا حتى تحكي شر اطلاقا لانه الشر
بنشر الشر ولا حتى تحكي الشر احكي الخير
واسكت شو رايك
فليقل خيرا او ليصمت بس هذا هو الامر
بدك تغير احوالك الان اذا بدك تقوم بهذه
الاوامر بدك تغير احوالك
بدك تغير الاشياء اللي بتخطر لك
وبدك تغصب نفسك انك تنشغل باشياء اخرى
هذا هو الامر
اما كلمه هدانا الله واياه استغفر نسال
الله ان والله هو صراحه زلمه كويس لكن
وهذه
هذا اللفظ هذا اللفظ الاستدراك ولكن ولكن
ياتي ولكن عشان يجيب الشر في الكلام على
الناس
وللاسف
الديانه الحقيقيه
اصبحت نادره بين المسلمين الان
عندنا ديانه ظاهره
والديانه العميقه الحقيقيه فانها اندر من
الكبريت الاحمر كما يقال كيف يعني
يعني
ما هو الاشد
ان تهين
تشبك
او
تعتدي
على اخيك المسلم
الخنزير
ما هو اشد حرمه
اشد حرمه في دين الله
تناول الميته ولا تناول من ولا التناول من
عرض اخيك
الجواب
التناول من عرض الاخ
هذا
تعدي وشر متعدي
لكن
ممكن تجلس في مجلس
ويغتاب فلان فلان فلان من الناس يغتاب
وفلان فلان من الناس نص ساعه ساعه
والثانيين
كلمه من هان وكلمه من هان ويزيدوا ويطلعوا
وينزلوا ويطلعوا اقتراحات الى غير ذلك
وبعدين ياتي ياتي الطعام فاذا اتى الطعام
يقولون الله الرز ما هو كويس لصحتك
الرز مش كويس لصحتك عرفت الرز والكولا
والخبز مش منيح لصحتك بس الغيبه منيحه
لصحتك
يشد الديانه هذه اللي احنا صرنا ندين بها
نكمل غدا ان شاء الله الله اعلم وصلى الله
وسلم على نبينا محمد